this is one of the most strategic gas
pipelines in the world called Nord
Stream at more than 1,200 kilometers in
length
it connects Russia to Germany and
provides gas to 26 million households in
Europe EU countries import 65% of the
gas consumption mainly from Russia
followed by Norway and Algeria it's a
very strong dependency that forces the
European Union to secure its gas
supplies and avoid any disruptions we
had such a crisis in 2009
previously in 2006 and even some member
states were without gas supply for two
or three weeks and it was a really
dangerous situation for our citizens it
would like to avoid such a situation a
proposal is on the table where in case
of a severe crisis EU states will have
to help their neighbors it's a
solidarity mechanism to protect the most
affected consumers solidarity it means
that in difficult times we can send gas
from one country to another to give
possibility of full gas supply to our
households two most important social
services like hospitals and to some gas
power stations to avoid blackout gas
companies will also be required to be
more transparent the new law will ensure
better cooperation between countries and
a more accurate assessment of common
risks
you